you thought 5 000 episodes was it enough
say it with me bros happy wheels
happy wheels thank you
we're back baby for another 100 episodes
of happy wheels we're starting a news
i'm not just foolish i'm just going to
play it once
you guys just couldn't have enough could
you your fantasies could never be
quenched
well here i am ah
the sweet sound of happy wheels it just
brings back all the memories
[Music]
anyway are you ready i got 100
subscribers
i missed you happy wheels let's freaking
do this so let's go by anytime and sort
by rating
harpoon dodge i'm glad to see they're
innovating
because i never played a harpoon dock
harpoon dodge two oh okay we're starting
with harpoon dodge two oh
easy three two one go
easy that one's easy i did it
i did it my god i'm so scared is this
oh god this is actually oh god not in my
i'm still alive i'm still alive it's
fine i'm
choking myself oh
that does not look good it's okay guys
i'm a little rusty
but i'll be i'll do it i'll do it i'll
do it control shift eject all right
i eject all right so you want to go as
flat as possible
oh you want to go dolphin
that's all i know that's all i remember
oh oh see this dolphin oh god
i'm actually having fun playing happy
wheels oh god it's hard it's hard
that's my head well we got a metal penis
everyone
is happy wheels gonna become like
minecraft or people people just start
playing it unironically again
i think i know what i need to do i think
i know what i need to do don't worry
about it
all right so you want to make sure that
that's it
oh damn it
i am so terrible
oh oh i'll take it i'll take it i'll
take it i may have lost my foot
but i'm still alive nope seal
oh yeah yeah i'm still alive god damn it
oh oh oh oh that's oh this is gonna hurt
oh my dodge dead
oh awesome oh that's not awesome
oh oh seal mode there it is damn i'm
good
once you get going this is easy oh
that's easy
the classic easy bring it happy wheels
i got years of experience yes
all right we're dropping down now i
don't know why my foot is coming with me
see you later foot live a good life
nani what is this
have they finally added checkpoints no
thanks for playing it
i hope you liked it have a nice day have
a nice day
have a nice day everyone harpoon dodge
one of course
of course cannot have enough of this
easy
[Music]
whoa oh
do one where i have to jump i have the
pogo
oh no i'm still alive i'm still alive
i'm still alive
i'm still alive i'm still alive so what
a [ __ ]
kind of bends up a bit and then control
dodges okay that's good to know
it went through my knees
[Music]
all right they i think they got my niece
i don't know what to tell you guys
all right i guess it's still coming i
did it
bottle flip none knee bottle flip
oh my god i'm a very pro noob
uh what all right what if we throw
backwards
[Music]
come on man come on
sniper i'm a sniper guys
this is it oh oh
this is it this is it this is it
[Music]
ah
create a meme face what
oh hell yeah meme face click language
uh i already failed clearly clearly
memes are only in spanish spanish that's
right
as click a key c
este
here we go we'll do the cereal meme i
love that means so much
all right what's next ah the eyes
okay uh
[Music]
[Applause]
burger i can't wait to see what my troll
face is gonna
i mean it's impressive why people did
this
there it is
to me sorry to interrupt this video just
want to give a big shout out to my boys
elgato the elgato hd60s to be specific
with this beautiful baby i can record
videos in the top quality
that i have and no i don't need the
camera i mean the gameplay footage
thank you maya she's on my side if only
elgato did cameras
then i would have such great quality but
until then check out the hd60s
you can record any form of gameplay
mobile phone
anything you can plug into your computer
almost thank you guys
rub swank i love roam swing
all right here we go rope swing
[Applause]
first try zero deaths let's freaking do
this rope swing baby
ah hell yeah yeah
[Music]
um
here we go
[Music]
yeah i'm still alive
i'm still alive
yeah let's go
come on arms grab grab grab
can i still drive with my handicapped
arm that is a question
ah bye arm it's been a play no ah
damn it
[Applause]
[Music]
there it is perfection so how do i go
here without dying
still alive baby oh we hit it we hit it
we're hitting
and then now we drop it drop it brown
and
down oh god oh god oh god thanks rap
baby
oh god what's gonna happen
pixel on my god it's minecraft
oh my god it's ma
am i supposed to go here okay i'll go
super mario wow
oh i'm writing i'm standing here
is this guy making the all the maps no
one else is making this map
nothing like winning in fetal position
oh ultimate glass break
[Music]
i can still do it son help me adjust my
spine ah
son that's not my spot well the comedy
has definitely increased
it's funny because now it's ironic get
up then
dad you could get
don't leave me dead all right
[Music]
okay ejected god damn it oh he's just
the top
[Music]
rated
how do i eject the sun please don't
eject me i'll let you did i let the
damage
why am i even playing this in garbage
ah ah [ __ ]
hell yeah now it's my time for that
sweet ass
trip
number one most subscribed everyone like
hell yeah you doing awesome dad
[Music]
yeah we made it oh we did it dan
thank you so much go no
no ha
[Music]
delicious i can finally eat well oh well
that was happy wheels
hopefully everyone is happy as happy
wheels
bro fest on 100 mil baby see you guys
tomorrow
bye also check out merch
link description what youtuber simulator
is becoming relevant
no no don't leave
no please sponsor eagle please
do something
yes
this game is still relevant god dammit